so come ospite nonostante il tema sia
quello che le figure di ricordo una che
pensandoci vorrei stato semplicemente un
momento passato con il mio primo
fidanzatino
ricordo che eravamo a casa sua spa
paranza t e sul network
ma improvvisamente la mia pancia
comincia a fare i rumori sospetti
in poche parole dovevo 1 sganciare aria
cercai di trattenerli ma il destino
volle che lui completamente a caso
comincia a farmi il solletico e in quel
caso installa l'utilizzo e frenare
l'aria che lo corpo voleva buttare fuori
è inutile dire che faccio
scusate la volgarità per favore una
delle scorregge più forti volevo
sotterrarli la parte carina però è che
ad un certo punto lui smette di ridere
mi guarda e dice sai che ti dico
e nulla di sgancio una più forte della
mia bellissima voce lei
ciao ragazzi bentornati una nuova
puntata di vita buttata il tema della
puntata di oggi figure di però non si
può dire figure di kakà
a 0 figure di feci feci figure prova
puntata così speciale ho deciso di
invitare qui all'interno degli studios
di casa mia una persona che appena passa
davanti a te ea proprio quello
no una persona con la quale veramente
potermi divertire con la quale poter
veramente ridere delle disgrazie altrui
più che con chiunque altro abbia
consecutio temporum oggi non è presente
ad un ospite d onore ospiti c'era mio
fratello enrico
eccoci qua cosa è pronto ascoltare le
figure di delle persone le figure del
sole vai pronto prontissimo così
partiamo accado ormai sei un
professionista di questo format tu stai
dormendo in piante dormito tre ore
quindi stai morendo
sono uscita con dei miei amici e siamo
andati diciamo in una simil discoteca
saranno le drag che intrattenevano un
sacco di alcol un sacco di di di persone
che ballavano discute vento abbastanza
il gomito
mi hanno raccontato che le drag mia
nemica da salire sul palco e mi hanno
eletto e miss
2015 che bello ma scusa quando un alza
il gomito e realtà balza anche quando
stand autobus comunque mazzata dove
viene il detto di alzare il gomito
mercanzin gomito ma col team medico ma
un picchetto sì perché penso ho preso
freddo a natale certo no sono guarito e
poi mi sono ri ammalato comanda che se
come retro c'è stato un periodo dove era
guarito ma uno si ammala quando sta bene
se sto sempre male
legare il concetto uno si ammala quando
sta bene ma se di euro compri male non
ti puoi ammalare se si è ammalato se già
malato e io infatti questa vicenda sta
sempre male ero guarito i modelli
distorti che vuol dire che saggezza
un'ora fi sarà guarito ciao ciao ospite
allora a parte il fatto che o un
abbonamento speciale alle figure di la
peggiore e più dolorosa che mi è
capitato è stata qualche anno fa quando
al termine di una partita io gioco a
calcio tra parentesi andiamo sotto la
curva 6 ci teniamo per mano mi sono
ritrovata in ospedale con una spalla
lussata allora non so se mi sono portata
sfiga ieri a raccontarti in questo mio
infortunio ma sappi che ieri sera mi
sono anche rotto il legamento crociato
vecchio sono una persona anche fortunata
parentesi delle vetture martinotti
impronte ady gil e perché di fermare
strisci domande nei viola lbj bug
staristi gente
non posso casa ospite oggi volevo
raccontare di quando volta che in
palestra stava male e praticamente
dovevo buttare una scoreggia detto ma lo
faccio non tre come perché tutti fanno
rumore non si sentiva bene abbiamo
cominciato un esercizio quindi abbiamo
cominciato a correre per la salta il
nonno
così decisi di farne al momento il
problema è che il coltello ne uscirò 1 a
pressione che senza pazienti da tutto
anche tutti si fermarono e ci sono
girati a guardarle che ci tenta di
niente sono caduto a terra multa non
troppo rumorosa e dire che potevo morire
e di una banca di roma 1 giu
e capitato anche a me cioè tipo che ne
so durante gli allenamenti
a me ad altri fortunatamente eravamo
tutti maschi quindi anni però è
succedere io invece io sono spesso in
treno roma milano milano roma napoli e
compagni diciamo in macchina tutti
quanti pensano che io in treno sia una
specie di vecchietta perché mi metto la
mia giacca sempre sulle gambe
la realtà è che se uno a volte alzasse
quello dello sciacca morire dentro è
corrosa hai un accendino e non può fare
nulla
io sarei morto di figure di germi
praticamente già all'epoca si portano
molto giochi sono al computer
ragioniamo in cooperativa questo
cosentino ci chiamavamo ogni tanto per
parlare la per fare le cose diciamo
coordinate no questo a mio cugino che mi
chiamo attratte tante tante volte
ragione mi chiamo portare fondi la
numerosa
antonio la rocca la mamma di salvatore i
tassi a me è successa subito
quella volta a volta in cui lui ha
voluto è stato punito
anch'io sono stato punito cioè che è
successo stavo al bar si avvicina a un
ragazzo e mi fa ha sofferto una domanda
e io sì sono io per lui non so chi sei
ma l'apple web come disastro vero
l'unica volta in cui mi si siano
avvicinati per chiedermi un qualcosa che
non fosse legata al canale io volevo
morire ancora valentina me lo ricorda
perché era lì davanti a me è scoppiata
al decreto ragione quell'altro basito io
immediato ma chi è questo sì
benedette dal meno sulle non c'è sembra
uno della apple
io e mia sorella abbiamo 13 anni
differenza le aveva sei anni quindi 19
mia sorella la racconta sempre si vanta
in quei momenti voi solo sprofondare
sbando mi fa ridere che la sorella di
qualche breve si possono misurare si
sono perse per i vari cortili dialetti
del condominio chi la nomina di sei
arrivi a riportare a casa la mia luce se
poi perché questo con freddo perché
server gordon si parlava di ciano
divertenti dico solo di e dalle diversi
e la mano venne ragazzo mi dice sempre
che lui doveva nascere seminate scorso
giorno è uscito a tavola aveva anche
tutti i parenti police in un enorme
tavolata e lo zio tengono non divertente
di turno ne ha cause ricorrenti a tutti
se ne beve di chiedermi se adesso ne
vale che una sia un pisello non si
vedeva se adesso fosse cresciuto oscura
mila voce perché sennò obbligarsi è qui
davanti ne sta rincorrendo ma è
cresciuto mandaci l'ecografia ma non ci
devono di arezzo
ma quindi quanta diciamo questo bambino
questo bambino è il culo non è
divertente non fa ridere ma è cresciuto
e unico graficamente svegliati tornando
perico svegliati ok ok ti pensavo che
avesse un figlio i giochi ero del coni
coni famiglia con il rigore
ragazzi siamo arrivati alla fine di
questo video come sempre che mai
scoraggiato lo scoraggiato nessuno
passare questo momento esatto
ciao raga della fine di questo video
ragazzi buie
[Risate]
realizzare di alla fine
[Applauso]
ragazzi sono arrivati al fine di questo
video fatemi sapere qua sotto scusa non
so parlare nei commenti quali sono state
le figure da proprio strong strong a
cioè quelle lì proprio che non vuoi
svegliarti il giorno dopo mi so niente
ha commentato la frase punto a capo
grazie tricot per aver fatto questo
video grazie a temi come sempre vi
chiedo di scrivervi di mettere un
pollice in su un gomito e soprattutto
attivare qua sotto l'ala campanellina in
modo non perdervi i prossimi episodi
noi comunque ci vediamo la prossima
settimana sempre in alcune un altro
video alle 14 ben detto
mai ciò io li devo dire ho deciso ma non
posso solo dare vuoi dire una cosa sì
allora